at the beginning of the week stewart's
checking account had a balance of
negative fifteen dollars and eight cents
so he owed the bank money he over
overdrew his checking account on monday
morning he deposited a check for 426.90
on tuesday morning he deposited another
check for a hundred dollars how much was
in stewart's checking account after the
second deposit so let's draw a number
line here just to help us
visualize what's going on so let me draw
and even though once you get enough
practice you won't have to draw these
number lines anymore at least for me i
find it helpful to at least visualize
them in my brain when i'm adding and
subtracting negative numbers so he
starts with negative fifteen dollars and
eight cents in his balance so this is
zero
that's zero over there he starts with a
negative number let me do that and let
me do that in a reddish color to show
that it's you know he's overdrawn his
balance so he starts with
negative fifteen dollars and eight cents
negative fifteen dollars and eight cents
so he's fifteen
and eight hundredths to the left of zero
so this the length of this arrow is the
absolute value of this which is fifteen
and eight hundredths so that's that
length right over here
now on monday morning he deposited a
check for 426.90
on monday morning he deposited a check
for 426.90
so he started here and we're adding
426.90 to that so you start here
you start here and you're adding 426
dollars and 90 cents to it i'm not going
to be able to draw it completely to
scale but hopefully it'll give you the
right idea so we're adding 426 dollars
to it
so the length of this blue arrow
is the 426 dollars and 90 cents so this
is a 426
426 dollars and ninety cents that's what
he's adding on monday so just after the
monday deposit how much does he have
left
well if you look at it here we can just
think about it visually the amount that
he has left is going to be the length of
this pink arrow right over here
it's going to be this pink arrow
right over here that's the amount that
he has left
and how would we calculate the pink
arrow
well clearly or maybe hopefully not well
hopefully it'll become more clear that
the length of this orange arrow plus the
length of this pink arrow is equal to
this blue arrow or another way to think
about it is the pink arrow is e the
length of the pink arrow which tells us
how far to the right we are of zero is
equal to the length of the blue arrow
minus the length of the orange arrow so
this over here
is going to be
it's going to be 426
426
i'm having trouble writing numbers
426.90
that's this length minus the length of
the orange i remember the length of the
orange jar is just the absolute value
you can't have negative length is just
going to be 15
minus 15 let me write it here
so minus 15 dollars
and
8 cents and so this is going to be equal
to let's see we can this will become a
10 this becomes an 8 so 10 minus 8 is 2
8 minus 0 is 8 we have lined up the
decimal points 6 minus 1 is
6 minus 5 is 1 2 minus 1 is 1 and then 4
minus nothing is 4. so this right here
we are at 411
and 82 cents that's how much he had
that's how much he had after monday
another way to think about it it was
426.90
plus negative fifteen dollars and eight
cents
if you think of it that way adding a
negative is the same thing as just
subtracting the positive so it's 426 90
minus 1508 but hopefully these arrows
give you a good visualization of what's
happening so that's where we are after
monday and then he deposits another
check
he deposits another check for a hundred
dollars
so we're going to go from 411 to 82 and
we're going to add another 100
we're going to add another 100
to that
we're going to add another
another hundred dollars and so that's
pretty straightforward we we're at 411
and 82. we're going to add another 100
to it so plus 100 this is going to be
511 and 82 dollars is how much he has
after the second deposit